[Music]
this story has been getting a lot of
attention in the last couple of days and
you may not have heard of it but it's
pretty amazing
it's comes out of Spain this story
apparently a 19th century painting of
Jesus that was hanging in a church got
what's being called the worst
restoration job ever yeah everyone's
talking about it's been online a lot
here's how the painting used to look
beautiful old 19th century painting and
it had some wear and tear and then one
of the churchgoers a woman named Cecilia
Jimenez who was in her 80s and is not a
painter took it upon herself to restore
the painting without asking anybody and
here is what she did to this rare and
valuable painting yes your reaction says
it all ladies and gentlemen
well the restoration job has become a
worldwide joke but one person wanted to
come on the show and defend the
restoration please welcome is
unbelievable the real Jesus here he is
let's talk to
I just want to say I just want to say
I'm very happy someone finally got it
right
[Applause]
none of us had any idea this is what you
really look like oh yeah that old lady
that Spanish lady kicked some ass
she got my lips right and I love the way
she captured my beard fro combo
[Applause]
[Music]